tenemos este problema de aquí dado un
triángulo abc de perímetro p en radio r
hay que determinar el área del triángulo
abc así se pone entre corchetes
en términos del perímetro y del radio
bueno aquí tenemos el triángulo abs el
perímetro p lo conocemos muy bien es
básicamente lo que está alrededor del
triángulo o cuando tendríamos que
utilizar de cerca para rodear este
triángulo vale lo que hay que acordarnos
un poco más de qué se trata es este y
radio r y bueno este en radio sale
justamente de trazar las bisectriz es
del triángulo abc así que déjame empezar
trazando eso voy a dibujar la bisectriz
del ángulo en a va a quedar más o menos
como por acá entonces sabemos que este
ángulo es igual este ángulo de aquí
luego voy a trazar la del ángulo b que
la voy a hacer en color rosa entonces
esta nos queda más o menos algo así vale
misma idea este ángulo de acá es igual a
este ángulo de acá y finalmente voy a
trazar la del ángulo c y como ya
probamos en vídeos anteriores esas
bisectriz es se intersectan en un único
punto y ese punto es al que llamamos el
centro el centro ahora este centro
cumple ser equidistante de los tres
lados de ave bc y sea eso básicamente
quiere decir que si bajamos
perpendiculares de iu a se ha de ir a
sea de a a b de ave más o menos algo así
y son perpendiculares perpendiculares y
de iu a b c d y abc entonces tenemos que
esas tres distancias esta esta y estas
son iguales esta es igual a esta que es
igual a esta bueno y luego decíamos que
iba había una circunferencia que pasaba
por este punto este punto y este punto y
que era tangente a los tres lados del
triángulo ahorita no necesitamos
dibujarla pero podría ser un intento
para que el dibujo quede un poco más
completo para ver más o menos algo así
algo así
bueno más o menos es la idea en fin
ahorita no la necesitamos tanto vale
lo que sí necesitamos es de alguna forma
pues meter el in radio para determinar
el área y una buena pista es que cada
uno de estos sin radios bueno cada uno
de estos segmentos es perpendicular al
lado correspondiente entonces podemos
pensar cada uno de estos sin radios como
las alturas de diversos triángulos del s
del c y b y del b y a entonces vamos a
dividir a dividir el área del triángulo
en el área de esos tres triángulos vamos
a utilizar el radio como altura y con un
poco de suerte va a aparecer el
perímetro por ahí vale bueno déjame
borrar el incyl culo para tener más
espacio para trabajar entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es justo eso vamos a
dividir el área del triángulo no quiero
un círculo más bien quiero el área del
triángulo a bs
a veces en el área de tres triángulos el
a y sé que voy a pintar de color rosa
ahorita lo pinto a hice entonces es esta
región de acá esta región de acá vale
más el área del triángulo se ve que voy
a pintar en rosa claro es como rosa
pastel entonces voy a sumar ya se me
antojó un pastel pero bueno se ve el
área del triángulo ceiba y finalmente le
voy a sumar el área del triángulo b y a
esta área de acá vale lo voy a sumar el
área del triángulo b y a muy bien y
entonces como te decía en cada uno de
estos triángulos tenemos que elin radio
es una altura entonces podemos poner que
el área del triángulo abc abc es igual
al área del a y c que sería un medio un
medio de la base que es hace hace por la
altura que celine radio por la altura y
luego tenemos que sumar el área de ceiba
qué es un medio un medio de la base que
se ve por la altura que otra vez ese
link radio y luego vamos a sumar vamos a
sumar el área debe a que es vea bueno
vamos a ponerle un medio de be a bueno x
vea x elin radio que es la altura es
esta altura de acá vale y observemos que
aquí tenemos un medio del radio en cada
una de las expresiones entonces vamos a
factorizar lo factor izando lo tenemos
que el área de abc es igual a un medio
un medio de link radio x x ac hace más
se ve más se ve más vea más vea y al
parecer ya terminamos porque observa
tenemos un medio del radio x hace más se
ve más vea pero hace más se ve más vea
es precisamente el perímetro del
triángulo a bs y de esta forma tenemos
que el área d
ángulo abc es igual a un medio voy a
poner el igual más bonito es igual a un
medio del radio multiplicado por el
perímetro y listo con esto respondemos
la pregunta el área del triángulo abc es
la mitad del producto del radio del
radio del círculo con el perímetro y
puede ser que algunas veces te
encuentres esta fórmula descrita un poco
diferente algunas personas les gusta
ponerlo como el radio multiplicado por
el perímetro entre 2 y a este perímetro
entre 2 se le conoce como el semi
perímetro le voy a poner aquí semi
perímetro cm y perímetro
y algunas personas les gusta denotar es
mi perímetro por s de esta forma puede
ser que también te encuentres esta
fórmula como el radio por el semi
perímetro vale donde esté mi perímetro
justo es el perímetro entre dos a mí
personalmente me gusta un poco más esta
fórmula porque pues tiene el perímetro y
no esta cosa rara que es el semi
perímetro pero bueno cualquiera de estas
dos fórmulas puede resultarte útil vale
va ahora nada más para terminar déjame
darte un ejemplo porque ver esta fórmula
está bien padre dado dado el área de un
triángulo y digamos sus lados te permite
calcular el radio y viceversa si
tuviéramos el link radio de un triángulo
y los lados entonces conocemos el
perímetro y por lo tanto podríamos
conocer su área pero déjame darte un
ejemplo de de cómo podemos utilizar eso
vamos a ponerle aquí ejemplo ejemplo y
vamos a tomarnos el triángulo rectángulo
quizás el más famoso que existe que es
el de la 2 3 4 y 5 vale entonces ahí
está el triángulo
el rectángulo de la 2 3 4 y 5
imagínate que nos piden determinar el
radio
bueno pues observa conocemos el área de
este triángulo el área de este triángulo
porque como es un triángulo rectángulo
su área área es simplemente un medio de
la base que es cuatro por la altura un
medio de cuatro es dos por 13-6 entonces
el área es igual a seis y de manera
similar también conocemos su perímetro
su perímetro de 54 que es 9 más 3 que es
12 entonces el perímetro que voy a
pintar con este otro color y el
perímetro es igual a 12 entonces p es
igual a 12 entonces vamos a aplicar esta
fórmula de acá vale tenemos que el área
el área
a área es igual a un medio por el
perímetro un medio por el perímetro
bueno por el radio vamos a poner primero
luego por el perímetro
déjame usar el color de perímetro por el
perímetro ahí está y entonces
sustituyendo ya voy a usar nada más el
color rosa tenemos que 66 es igual a 12
que es el perímetro entre 2 es igual a 6
r y por lo tanto el radio es igual a 1 y
este es un resultado bien bonito lo que
nos dice es que si tenemos aquí el
triángulo 345 y trazamos el in círculo
estamos el in círculo más o menos algo
así un poco más hacia acá entonces ese
que no quiere quedar ahí está entonces
es un círculo tiene radio 1 y ese me
parece un resultado bastante padre vale
bueno entonces aquí está una aplicación
esta es la fórmula que tenemos espero
que te haya gustado este vídeo